I'm very happy to be here I'm also a
little nervous because my wife is
backstage and she could go into labor at
any moment so I gotta get out of here so
let's wrap this up fast we'll get right
into it I was recently out of town and
taking an uber back to my hotel and as I
got into the car the driver said comfort
in and I said yes
comfort in where king sleep and he said
nothing and then just turned the music
up even louder and I was like ooh
somebody doesn't like my sense of humor
I was like determined to get him to
laugh so I leaned forward in the song it
turned up was a brown-eyed girl and I
leaned forward I just went hey do you
know Van Morrison has gone on record as
saying brown-eyed girl wasn't written
about a butthole but he's okay if you
interpret it that way nothing from him I
was like okay you know we'd all have to
agree that I'm funny you know like my
dad always said there's a two sides to
every coin and if there's not it's
probably not a coin it's probably a ball
or something dad had weird sayings and
but we kept talking and I found out that
when he's not driving uber he actually
works in a factory that manufactures
tractor tires and I was like that's
amazing I very rarely meet someone who
makes something actually useful to the
world and he said we mostly just sell
him to CrossFit gyms Donald Trump is
president that's insane I I was what was
crazy about it is that the majority of
people voted for Trump were married men
most with families so now we know who
the enemy is
dad's and I'm about to be a dad so
that's why I'm starting dad's against
dads aka dad's Ravenel a lot of branding
problems right now differentiate
ourselves from just regular dads but
we'll figure it out we'll figure it out
and but I am I'm very excited to be a
dad and I know that I'm ready to be a
dad because I was recently trying to
remember the name of Celine Dion and I
kept calling her rene claude de
so to the point where I had to Google
who is rene claude a and then work
backwards to figure out it was Celine
Dion and the Google spread like GU we
asked Google everything like Google's
gonna take over the world it's so scary
but I had a heartening thing happen to
me recently is that Google starts
showing me ads for doors I don't own a
house I didn't I didn't even know you
could buy a door I thought they came
with walls but I was excited I was like
that means Google doesn't have me
figured out yet like my search history
is so erratic that Google's just like I
don't know and it is it's very erratic
everyday it's just like before after
meThe picks boat launches handkerchief
twirling and I think Google looked at
that and was just like seems like you
need a way out
George so I've been buying a ton of
doors and I'm gonna put them up I just
you know just to mess with the algorithm
I just throw them around the house
put a little inspirational signs on
every doorknob you know cuz that's how I
lived my life of inspirational signs on
doorknobs the one I'm into right now
just says do one thing every day that
scares you so I've been doing that last
week got herpes I'm gonna try heroin
tonight oh so scared I'm gonna love it
and tomorrow I'm gonna steal a cop's gun
cuz it's just a snap it's a snap holding
the gun down that's it just a snap
honestly that scares me so much every
time I see a cop all I'm like I could do
it like snap up got a gun you know it's
a snap it's Mennonite technology holding
the gun down step up got a gun you know
practice in the mirror like how fast
snap I've got a gun I'm just kidding ha
ha ha I'm kidding I'm a tall white man
you got there's so much fun let me show
you how to shoot it
[Applause]
you